Bây giờ mình sẽ không lên vi giúp vời và cùng không bao giờ nói nhiều người thì bây giờ
Tuy theo cả có suy nghĩ và tí cho các đông mà suy nghĩ vi là vi sản là có một số bà viết bà,
bà viết bà, bà tài trởi vì thế lắng viết.
Bà viết viết, bà tài trởi thích, tìm viết.
Bà viết, có đông mà hêu, viết mình là kênh ngay không xa dịch định,
viết sẽ lên viết cho các đông.
Thuy nhất là bộ mình là tình thành 2, 2 năm món gài là tông sự dung.
Bà, mình là tổn là và 2 năm em tà mình được lất.
Công đông sự dung.
Thuy không bự ngột thế này cả và khi cả có một chế nhà,
nhưng mình cũng sẽ nha là phía phó kia bước sản muốn này là bước vè đã trở đầu viết.
Bây giờ, a mình sẽ nha vè không ở mở, còn không phế nhà thì bây giờ.
Là bây giờ, bây giờ, bây giờ dung cũng có thể 2 nha là không đi.
Là làm biệt, hình là 3 thêm biệt.
Chết thơ, biệt, hình có.
Bán giào tổn nhá, mình sẽ đi về đó mà xa.
Thuy không bao giờ, bây giờ, bây giờ mạng gái cả.
Cảm ơn, mình có biệt, và hình hình hình gái không nhiều đó,
các bạn không biết thế nào cho.
Đất mới không hả, đất ra, là bạn là nhiều.
Các trặng một trà mình tâm đi.
Tìm nó fân trà mà bản rồi, vàng rồi đi.
Đà bản là thế hoà mà, để làm cái giĩ lính zinh nhiều.
Đánh biệt, nhưng mà, lời, lời, lời, lời, lời, lời, lời, lời, lời, lời, lời mình lời, mình lời, bình lời, mình lời,
Tại sao? Mình sẽ nhớ con phía
Vậy bây giờ nè
Bây giờ nè
Bây giờ hướng và bây giờ nè
Con chào mùn vê là cười vê là cười vê là cười vê là cười vê là
Các tiền khán phát tiền, có chào đấu khán đấu khán đấu khán đấu khán đấu khán đấu khé cả mấy ông
Mặc là thái nửa là
Làm bây giờ đông sự dùng là nắm mẫu và bụ bình
Mà bình bêm ra bình
Làm bây giờ đông sự dùng mùn
Làm gái chiến của mình được sự nhất quyệt tâm nhá
Mặc là chỉ đặt cho đoồn sẽ nhá là đông theo nổi ý của mình
Thì cả có nổi lời lời
Thứng trá
Thứng trá là sẽ nhá là trá
Thì mình vẫn đông hông vàng bọt tiền
Các ông mình sẽ tỏng đứa sẽ nhau đưa
Thì ra gặp là đấu
Mình có tên tró
Tứ phải mình không cóm đâu
Như vì vậy, mình vẫn nói với cản có có cảm thấy con bây giờ sẽ nhá lời đâu
Các ông sẽ đứng mô và tình mô sẽ nhóm người gọt
Thì sao nhi là mình là mình là mình là mình sẽ nhá
Thì có nha bởi vì nó có tâm đều
Mình có ví giá có vía không?
Trúc không phải là mình nhi nào
Trần ra mình bạn đã trôi nhé mình bạn đã thể chỉ về tánh chấp
Các bạn có đông bạn thì thì không phải là mình tánh chấp là tệ ở và để
Bạn mới trìm nhé, nhưng tài nhé mình là khẩm ở đây
Đặt nhé mình ở ở ở ở ở chỗ khả, nhưng tài nhé mình vẫn chưa ở nhá vấn khu